a major shift in this Trump
administration's approach to the
coronavirus by setting up a new group to
focus on reopening the country now
President Trump made his first trip away
from the Washington area in weeks and
toward a facemask factory in Arizona he
and up he and rather top company
executives did not wear one even though
most of the workers there did have one
on now the president says he's looking
at winding down the coronavirus task
force that includes his top medical
advisors meanwhile a whistleblower is
accusing the administration of ignoring
early warning signs and downplaying the
virus threat Paula Reid is at the White
House for us Paula good morning
the president is openly acknowledging
that more American lives could be lost
as the country reopens economically so
timing wise why does all of the task
force in the near future a good morning
Tony the president's announcement
appeared to take some task force members
by surprise shortly after the vice
president told reporters that he was
having conversations about winding down
the group's work we reached out to one
of the most prominent members of that
task force dr. Anthony Fauci he told CBS
News he had heard no such thing the task
force has done a phenomenal job as he
toured a mask production facility in
Arizona President Trump suggested his
coronavirus task force of medical
experts may be dissolved as the White
House shifts its focus from saving lives
to reopening the economy we're now
looking at a little bit of a different
form and that form is safety and opening
and will will have a different group
probably set up for them the move to
disband the task force comes as some
coronavirus models predict deaths will
increase in the coming weeks as areas
around the country begin to reopen but
President Trump dismissed those dire
predictions so report with no mitigation
frankly when the people report back
they're going to be social distancing
are they're going to be watching their
hands and they're going to be doing the
things that you're supposed to do but
the models do take mitigation into
account and are based on the relaxing of
social distancing that the president has
been calling for president Trump
continued to praise his own response to
the pandemic while trying to shift blame
to prey
an Obama don't forget the cupboard was
bare the other administration the last
administration left us nothing pressed
on why he didn't do more to prepare
president said he was busy well I'll be
honest I have a lot of things going on
we had a lot of people that refused to
allow the country to be successful they
wasted a lot of time on Russia Russia
Russia that turned out to be a total
hoax but one government doctor Rick
Wright said he tried to raise alarms
about the pandemic back in January and
was ignored bright filed an extensive
whistleblower complaint alleging that he
told his superiors that the u.s. was
woefully short on n95 masks and
suggested putting together a disaster
leadership group to address the pandemic
in the complaint bright alleges HHS
official dr. Robert Cal dick suggested
it was appropriate but he was not sure
if that is a time-sensitive urgency
brights lawyer Deborah Katz spoke to CBS
News the administration was very intent
on providing good news and in
sugarcoating how devastating this virus
going to was going to be bright says he
was moved to another department after he
resisted pressure to widely promote
hydroxychloroquine an anti-malaria drug
championed by President Trump he said he
was concerned that HHS actions would
seriously harm or even kill members of
the American public bright also alleges
that since 2017 he was pressured to
steer government contracts to companies
with ties to the Trump administration
and we've reached out to the
administration for its reaction to those
allegations but so far they've only said
that dr. bright was transferred to a
role that now focuses on testing and
that they're disappointed he hasn't
shown up for his new job Anthony Paula
Reid of the White House Thank You Paula